giving it yeah hey Gilda I went though a
couple of childhood friends come to
visit Angelo and Lucho this is Christin
I seemed nice you know they were
Peruvian spoke broken English but they
did you know speak a little bit English
so we were able to you know speak with
them anyway
it was hung around the house I need time
we left they were there any time we came
home they were there hey can we talk to
you for a second
yeah what's up so one day Angelo and and
Lucho called us into the living room
they asked us how our night was and and
what time we'd gotten in and we had fun
and we're like okay what is this small
talk you know so we were just talking
about it and we want to give you guys
the opportunity to go to Peru everything
included for a few weeks all expense
paid trip to Peru you know we wanted to
travel
it was Peru we'd never been there and we
were like wow you go over there you hang
out with our friends they'll take you
you want to go shopping you'll go
shopping you'll do whatever you want
they made it sound like it was the Rio
de Janeiro or something we'd be going on
the vacation of our lives the beaches
are beautiful the water's blue
well hesitant because not understanding
why they're going to pay for us to go to
Peru know what you just you just have to
bring something a little bit extra so
look at your plane tickets look at your
passports you just have to bring
something a little extra back in your
bag
we're like okay what and they said a
little bit of cocaine it's just a little
small amounts it's no big deal it's like
bringing a pair of tennis shoes in our
bag it was it was nothing and they told
us that the bags were you know
everything was professional everything
was professionally spent thousands of
dollars on on making these bags we would
not even be able to see that see the
drugs you know they have a way of doing
it to where it's put in the seam of your
bag and you know basically we wouldn't
even be able to tell that it was there I
asked what you know what if we would get
caught what if we do get caught and I
remember them specifically saying this
is something that did stick in my mind
they said there will there's no way that
you will get caught there's no way trust
me you'll pay five thousand dollars each
cash you have a couple days to think
about it will mean thirsty